- Bladesmiths, this is the kill
test.
We'll take your Sica
sword and deliver killing
blows on this ballistics dummy.
Frank, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Hell, yeah.
Let's do this.
I'm feeling good, yet anxious.
I put my all into this blade.
I'm just hoping it just takes
the head right off this dummy.
Nice!
Well, Frank, your
blade is sharp.
In combat, the Sicas sometimes
used this curve to pull
away the sword and come in.
In this case, it
pulled away the head.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Thank you.
Tony, are you ready?
Mm-hmm.
Let's have some fun.
Frank's blade just
did awesome in this.
I mean, the head came off.
I'm hoping mine will
do the same thing.
We'll just unleash
hell onto this dummy.
All right, Tony.
This is a scary Sica sword.
On the initial hack
into the chest cavity,
it penetrated so deep,
it totally demolished
this ballistics dummy.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
Tony's blade just performs
great on this thing.
I mean, even though
they both will kill,
his just looked a
little bit more violent.
So it has me a little nervous.
Gentlemen, this is
the strength test.
In order to test the strength
and durability of your blades,
I'm going to attack
these shields.
Remember, this test
is all about what
a shields do to your
weapons, and not what
your weapons do to the shields.
Frank, you're up first.
Are you ready?
- Yep.
Let's do this.
Well, Frank, your
edge held up perfectly.
It's still straight,
it's still sharp.
Everything is still
tight and solid.
Well done.
Thank you.
Tony, you're up next.
Are you ready?
- Yes.
Well, Tony, your edge
held up perfectly as well.
Razor sharp.
I see no problem with
the edge from the shield.
In all, a nice solid blade.
Well done.
Thank you.
Great job, man.
All right, gentlemen.
Now it's the sharpness test.
I'll be cutting through
this sugar cane.
One cut with the front
edge of your blade,
one cut with the back edge.
All right, Frank,
you're up first.
Are you ready?
- Hell, yes.
All right, Frank, right
off, your blade's got
a really nice balance to it.
You can see on that first cut
it kind of pulled in my hand,
but it's still a good feel.
On the back cut,
blew right through.
Any gladiator using this would
be quick and would be deadly.
Well done.
- Thank you.
All right, Tony.
You're up.
Are you ready for this?
Yep.
I'm a little nervous, because
this is going to be the test--
the performance of my blade.
Without a great cutting
edge, you don't have a blade.
It's time for my
blade to pony up.
So, Tony, is it sharp?
Yes.
It's very sharp and
it cut very nicely.
It's still right, still tight.
Well done.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, over the course
of three rounds, both of you
has displayed excellent
bladesmithing talents.
However, in this
arena of competition,
there can only be one champion.
Tony, congratulations.
You are the new Forged
in Fire champion.
Frank, unfortunately your
weapon did not make the cut.
Frank, first up, I
want to say that there
are no losers in this round.
But we can only pick one winner.
Both weapons were very sharp.
Both weapons are very strong.
But the Sica was a
gladiators' weapon,
and your weapon was out
performed in the kill test.
It is for that reason
we're sending you home.
I totally understand.